let's go girl Shania Twain is back and
better than ever appearing on the newest
cover of people hitting newsstands
Nationwide Friday the country music icon
says she feels A Renewed confidence as
she gears up for the release of her
sixth studio album queen of me it's a
really beautiful maturity to be
experiencing and to be experiencing it
as a relevant artist still but the road
to where she is now wasn't an easy one
following a divorce from her husband and
a seven year fight with Lyme disease
that affected shania's ability to sing
she opened up about that time period
saying quote I would call it a handicap
I was robbed of a physical ability but I
was less afraid in that surgery than I
was
[Music]
of never being able to sing again
creativity really saved me a lot I've
put myself to
um
[Music]
kind of you know set myself on that uh
creative course
to stay positive
[Music]
I have power and I can sing and I can
yell and I can
um
I can do it and that brings me a lot of
joy for more video go to peopletv.com